in this video we're going to try to
understand limits of composite functions
or at least a way of thinking about
limits of composite functions
and in particular we're going to think
about the case where we're trying to
find the limit as
x approaches a of f
of g of x and we're going to see
under certain circumstances this is
going to be equal to
f of the limit
the limit as x approaches a of
g of x and what are those circumstances
you are asking
well this is going to be true if and
only if two things are true
first of all this limit needs to exist
so the limit
as x approaches a of g of x needs to
exist so that needs to exist
and then on top of that the function f
needs to be continuous
at this point and f
continuous at
l so let's look at some examples and see
if we can apply
this idea or see if we can't apply it
so here i have two functions that are
graphically represented right over here
let me make sure i have enough space for
them
and what we see on the left hand side
is our function f and what we see on the
right hand side
is our function g so first
let's figure out what is the limit
as x approaches negative 3 of
f of g of x pause this video
and see first of all does this theorem
apply and if it does apply what is this
limit
so the first thing we need to see is
does this theorem apply
so first of all if we were to find the
limit as
x approaches negative 3 of g of x
what is that well when we're approaching
negative 3
from the right it looks like our
function is
actually at 3. it looks like when we're
approaching negative 3 from the left it
looks like our function is at 3.
so it looks like this limit is 3 even
though
the value g of negative 3 is negative 2
but it's a point discontinuity as we
approach it from either side the value
of the function
is at three so this thing is going to be
three
so it exists so we meet that first
condition and then the second question
is
is our function f continuous at
this limit continuous at 3. so when x is
equal to
when x equals 3 yeah it looks like at
that point our function
is definitely continuous and so
we could say that this limit is going to
be the same thing
as this equals f of
the limit as x approaches negative 3
of g of x close the parentheses
and we know that this is equal to 3
and we know that f of 3 is going to be
equal to negative 1.
so this meant the conditions for this
theorem and we were able to use the
theorem to actually solve this limit